you described GG as beautiful and feisty
no is it
we all knew her dad as a player but what
about GG hard for you because yeah it's
crazy cuz I've been good because I I
don't think about it a lot and for me it
just it's still not real so I'm just
seeing that connection and knowing how
important his family was to him all his
girls Vanessa it's still tough for me to
cut my hand to understand but um when
Cole found out he was having his baby
girl you know I remember I was seeing I
saw him I was like man another girl
another girl I was like you know what
that me got to keep going till you get a
boy you got to keep going we used to
joke about that all the time and he used
to just tell you you know me I went do
you see GG what do you see it and
there's no connection like that I talked
to some of my friends and you know you
can have five kids six kids two kids
whatever there's always you know one of
your kids that there's just different
yeah just different they gravitate to
you differently
my son is probably that way with me as
my daughter is to my wife and I just
always smile if Cole was at a game and
be a game she was right there you know
there's no greater fellow does he give
you any comfort knowing that they were
and are forever together yes cuz I'm
just visual and I can I can I don't know
I just can't stop my mom but uh she GG
was with her protector she was with her
dad and I mean and she wouldn't rather
be in any other place so uh cold man who
he is would you know right now probably
hit hit my chin out
tell me to keep it together you know and
just keep going do you ever think back
and think about what if what if that
happened and we actually did get that
opportunity to play together hey man you
know it's crazy our life happens and
it's just so precious the opportunity to
play together would have been crazy
because we went so hard against the
other was competing against each other
but one of the funniest things ever was
when he tweeted that picture our kids
you know and he said at least Gigi and
lo Chris to get a chance to play
together and I don't know it's just it's
still tough what does Mamba mentality
mean to you man it's just like old I was
a killer that's another level yeah yeah
it is my coach is like some people say
like he different no like he was really
different but I remember being a [ __ ]
around that morning and he could break
the record against us and I was in New
Orleans and he was the shooter and
Russell Butler I rest in peace another
one of my brother's was gonna be guard
code and we looked at each other we was
like ain't breaking every cold my dad
20200 first order you know I mean he
just he just different like that you
just his work ethic
it was just contagious and even still to
this day when I watched videos of him or
whatever like he never let age slow him
down and nothing like that it was just
you know i'ma work hardening I think one
of the most beautiful things I've seen
out of this just talking to a lot of my
friends who played in the NBA who know
Kobe who were friends with Toby all of
them have said to me Michelle we didn't
understand how this would hit us but we
have all as men taken stock a lot of us
have gotten together sat together cried
together talked about our feelings
really went to a vulnerable place that
we never even knew we could be in mellow
right one of one of my closest friends
is somebody who I talked to for a very
long
and we talked about that this isn't
something that you get over today
tomorrow maybe not even a year from now
not even a few years from and you just
never know when it's gonna hit you or
you gonna feel it but we got to have
each other to talk to about it
absolutely and I think that's the
importance of friendships and
Brotherhood's or whatnot is being able
to have people that you can lean on you
know when when times are hard like this
how do we go forward how do we honor him
going forward in his legacy to really
and truly like live for today and try to
inspire others you know and I think a
lot of times people look at athletes so
what we doing for kids right we're cold
inspired grown individuals you know
husbands wives whatever and to see the
mark that he has put on the game and to
us home yeah yes still not real